the piano man you guys don't have the
piano anymore bud
what piano mon
piano remember
i never had a piano in the whole plays
he's thinking about stevie's show you're
my brother's show oh yeah yeah
did you do stevie's show i was like dang
stevie looks like he's uh
[Laughter]
pretty rough
rough bruh oh yeah sorry man turn the
cameras in diana is you'll get the
recording instruments going on or
whatever at least yes sir all right you
can do the countdown or what man five
four three two my body tells me no oh
but i won't quit cause i want more more
more
more welcome to [ __ ] tiger belly
i am your captain
papaya
king usa slash korea we got [ __ ] flat
place
we got flat flace oh yeah it is a little
much yeah it's all right right
because you can still see yeah i like
that man yeah and i'm back you get five
better at hide and seek
we got my beautiful princess right here
kalylah you know i mean she's uh
you mean everything's like a virgin with
her man everything's tight and nice you
know what i mean she had a great
personality and uh wow i love her so
much she's my life partner man
we travel life together bro and we
explore oh it's good i haven't said your
name so you don't [ __ ] say [ __ ] until i
introduce you okay rat
violent bob i like this yeah i like my
new yeah yeah i really like your new i
feel like you're really that guy and we
also got that guy and that guy
let's clap everybody now listen that uh
oh [ __ ] dude i had no idea that you
brought your mythological friend over
here from the [ __ ] you know i mean uh
yeah pandora bro this guy that's my
friend colin dude your left sack is like
my head your head
yeah
i don't know what i just said my your
head is like my left back is what i
meant to say he got that body set he got
that body yeah yeah anyway good to see
you man you got that beautiful mind
anyway this next guy i'm going to
introduce is our guest tonight
um
wow i like it wow i was like commercial
that's just the sound i make when i show
up
release attention so bro you know years
ago dude i did not know anything about
country people man so i went to a
restaurant and i got a biscuit you know
i mean
bro
your biscuits bro
bro with the jalapenos sometimes you put
it in there bro what's the [ __ ]
butter you don't do that
people came over here and started doing
that dude
okay
my bad i didn't know the history of it
bro yeah but let me just finish dude
i'll bring you up dude
uh i like the collard greens i like the
uh
that's all i had but i want to say to
you dude that um
i've been going through a hard time in
my life i really have
and um
you know i wanted to push some of these
pods because you know i would try to get
my head straight but
when i realized it was you dude i was
like let's do it because um
i view you as somebody that i think is
incredibly one of the funniest guys and
number two
you and i are um
friends for real um
you've changed a little uh with your
bling and i've never seen you wear a
purple scarf before but um
and
it's there's no sun out
this is
this is i actually wore these glasses in
memory of your father because i haven't
even seen you really since your father
passed away
thank you
morning are you crying these are morning
no morning oh you are would you want to
see his dad you want to see my dad here
turn it around turn around gable
is he in that thing
don't be careful what the [ __ ] are you
doing what is that giving you give me
the baby give me the baby oh my god you
have no idea what you just did
be careful their ashes come come out
there he is bro
robert h lee yeah that's my dad right
there bruh yeah beautiful one say hi huh
what he's small he was a pygmy dude
was he really yeah he was one foot two
and that's we didn't even put ashes in
him that's just his whole body a little
shoulder man yeah he's a shoulder man
yeah so my dad is one foot two they fit
him in that little box and he's still
alive he's just resting yeah little
holes in the bottom you know put him out
on the other side man see you on that
side um thank you so much um i didn't
say your name how about a run of
applause for theo vaughn everybody clap
your hands man thanks guys he has his
own um podcast called weekend wars with
theophone and uh what's the
past weekend with
last week yeah yeah riffing with theovan
or whatever
neovon
yeah drinking my way to rehab what's
that new podcast
that's very personal oh whiskey ginger
my bad
whiskey ginger yeah yeah
dude i feel like i'm at the weirdest
barber shop
ever yeah so dude you just got i was
like is anybody gonna come
this [ __ ] is no one of the [ __ ] has two
stars
i feel like that's something we should
um hash out right mullet versus mullet
deal
well there's nothing you know i'll be
honest with there's no hash out to be
happen you know it's like you know a
friend of mine
right showing it always relaxing
you know a friend of mine dude oh you
have that native yours is more native
yeah my name is mine is definitely a
little bit more british one guy with a
drum in front of me you know yeah yeah
yeah i got it
yeah in front of me dude somebody throws
something somebody throws a freaking
pineapple over your shoulder or
something somebody throws a yeah it's
more native somebody throws a spear yeah
somebody carves you up and makes a
[ __ ] chubby soup you know
that's your style but anyway
dude
i got this
because i was so inspired by your look
bro oh thanks man i mean your sexuality
you didn't even ask me about it you just
got it no i because i don't think i need
to ask it's like you know what back in
the 80s dude when like people got
parachute pants
right my buddy ramone
got parachute pants oh yeah yeah eddie
is he a man and he was like and he was
like pop locking and [ __ ] right i didn't
call him go hey
can i buy those two and do the same
moves
no i just i made my mom go to
nordstrom's
yeah and i got the ones with the most
pockets that's one way to do it man
you know i think though if i would have
said like hey i want to
you know
put on a little put on a couple pounds
you know and maybe chop
chop a couple inches out of each one of
my
legs you know what if i want to do that
you know what if i want to
you know
[Music]
what if i want to kind of make myself
look like i had just at the very end of
a sneeze you know
then
but i didn't call you first you know
that's how i'm feeling like i just
that's the only thing i thought let me
think about that you know
well you know touche
yeah tuesday to you well right right
and touche okay and good day sir okay
all right but what i want to reiterate
back to you dude is is i could have
i could have done this
then bleached my skin
right and then taken some brain cells
out of my brain
right right like
the philosophical ideas of my life yeah
right and then i could have added a
couple of inches to my legs
right got a truck
right and then peed on your lawn like
you just peed on mine earlier yeah i had
to pee that's why what happened he peed
up
you know did you pee on the concrete or
did you pee on a plant
it's a little got on the concrete but
not that much so mostly plant
so
as long as it was you know absorbent
it's fine yeah yeah that's that concrete
looks pretty absorbent yeah yeah i think
yeah so what you're saying to me is i
should have called you
yeah i said hey buddy
um next time i see you
yeah
i we look alike then right
but yours is different than mine yours
is much more
like of the
it's more mowgly i feel like you know
i'm saying his is just more
um
you know more like oh like missing
person style ah
like an 80s kind of uh synth band yeah
something like that or this guy's oh
have you seen this guy and he's like no
i haven't seen him man never seen him
you know and they just keep showing the
picture around town you
know did walking disappear mowgli yeah
no no no no he was raised by a bear uh
wolves initially
educate me
yeah
and then
i thought he was the lead singer of
missing persons for a second
you were talking about
he's talking about donald trump
yeah he's talking about jungle books
i think you're talking about mowgli
missing per i thought missing persons
was the 80s band you were talking about
and mowgli was the lead singer
of missing person oh no uh sorry man
that was my bad though
it's both of our bad dude i can't even
believe we get into conversations
because
[Music]
i know that's what our conversations are
like on on the phone oh it's
unbelievable yeah we talked about we
were talking about i'm like different
topics yeah yeah the phone cut out
you're like
oh okay
neither one of us is getting anywhere so
welcome to another episode of tiger
belly
welcome you know um i didn't know
oh you knew
ah i didn't i didn't you knew there was
a snake in the mail
accusations anyway we got the human
embodiment here i'm gonna make a sound
and you tell me if it reminds you of you
going to the post office okay okay
[Laughter]
yeah
it's it seems familiar
yeah yeah
wait in line at the post office bubbe so
um theo vaughn oh you little spiked
skunk hey [ __ ] you
hey bro hey bro don't call me that you
want to bring a swordfish to a gunfight
you little piss guppy
don't say that
i'm a piss cop you sent me those dirty
dishes and you sent the snake bubba
first of all i don't know where where
the [ __ ] you live in nashville number
two it's like why would i if i was gonna
were they poisonous the snakes the snake
was a rat snake bub right bub can they
kill you bob huh can they kill you bob
they can't kill me
why huh you only send one
right right if you want to kill me
you need to say mas yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so i would have sent maybe 10 of
them right and they're more poisonous
than the whatever the gutter one what's
that the rat what's the gutter whatever
the rat snake would i could send them it
was a rat snake rat snake i was in a box
it was dishes that that was sent
you know this it was dishes that was
sent it was little uh chinese little
cups or something like kind of shaped
like this and had those spoons that also
has a you know the spoon you all have
that as a bowl on the end it's kind of
[ __ ] cheating honestly but you know
what
what do you mean just the really deep
ones yes i do just oh you mean for the
soup yeah for whatever yeah they're soup
[ __ ] spoons bro bro is it a bowl
whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do all right yeah
yeah
it's a spoon yeah yeah whatever dude
these [ __ ] little pinoy ladles you
know
yeah yeah
okay dude
the things you scoop up all your
[ __ ]
yeah yeah anyway it's a box of little
asian dishes they're all wrapped in
newspaper uh-huh so i open it up there's
no return address it's from los angeles
but there's it says on the sticker thing
but there's no
um
return address
so i'm like i wonder who sent this
literally i go do some other stuff in my
house i come back over there three
minutes later and there's a snake right
outside of it that's moving around in my
home
whoa where do i live bubby
a wall was it not funny
because
my intention i think i came here to
probably
bro bro my bro
if i wanted to
if i wanted to kill you you'd be dead
already
right yeah so i do things for a chuckle
yeah right so when you saw the little
dishes and that little bold spoon thing
right and the little
snake right did you get a chuckle out of
it
no i thought who sent me the chinese
ramekins or whatever right right right
but after you went through that thought
process right you thought elise sent it
and that's funny i thought who do i know
that's chinese or semi-chinese yeah i'm
not chinese though semi a semi-chinese i
am semi-chinese but if you played your
cards right you could have been
all right you mean before i even came to
earth i'm just saying dude
if you do your bts [ __ ] work you
[ __ ] show up like you want right
okay i [ __ ] it up up there huh before
i came i'm not saying that but right
it's been said yeah
all right okay i'm just saying so don't
send me snake bro all right bro
my bad dude okay that was gonna get a
charcoal but my bad dude very scary yeah
okay you know how hard it was to get
that snake
i had to go all the way to monterey park
to get that okay
there are mexican peoples dressed up
like asian people selling snakes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay half that park is a bunch
of asians and finding your address was
tough bro yeah really yeah yeah public
knowledge okay all right but you know
what i thought it was gonna be funny but
i apologize man if it scared you a
little bit it did scare me yeah yeah are
you gonna send me something or what
keep in mind that i open all the mail so
it's gotta be something
oh
well have you heard that justin
timberlake song what is it
what's wrong there's so many dude the
one with the uh it's like mail they sent
it's like a um dick in the box oh is
that it no
this guy dude
this guy i would never send that and
that is a joke interesting
laugh either okay
yeah mark [ __ ] white berg over there
just freaking oh one of owen benjamin's
henchmen
do you have any tips about um getting a
mullet and how to maintain a mullet
because uh captain lee is gonna get it
you're ready to go deep i think a good
person to
um to look at is riff raff you know
and riff raff is a he's almost like a
human animal out of florida and if you
look at that man he is very he really
has perfected it you know do you think
he should work his way into riff raff
should he start some with something like
a milder mullet is there such a thing
there's nothing mild about a mullet
right you're committing bro think the
crazy part is the second you freaking
grow that thing you'd look good in one
actually man
yeah definitely but what about me bruh
you
are gonna have one soon she said
yes you know what dude and i think it
could be cool i think you you're
definitely gonna love it i think you
should have it i think you know what you
are lucky
that you can um
be like that movie um last in the
mohicans
[ __ ]
they do yeah oh but he didn't have a
mullet bro daniel they leave
yeah my right foot
i'm gonna do movie call my right foot
right but i can't do no i can't draw
nothing with it yeah and your foot's
always asleep that's it yeah
and then it gets like gangrene and i
have to lose it whatever you know i mean
we'll write the script i could see you
having a beautiful mullet though
and i think thank you yeah i really
could man and i think it's time man i
think it really would inspire you to
feel like a different person
and make these guys do them dude make
these whites in here [ __ ] grow them
[ __ ] i might have everyone and even
the [ __ ] gooks in here too right yeah
some of the i don't know
i don't know who is a [ __ ] but yeah
yeah yeah no idea came out smoothly bro
very good i feel like you've said that
word before bruh
i mean i've said it i just don't know
who it's at
that's the problem dude that's not a
problem that's really the benefit you
know but i'll tell you why the mama
brought because um you know my people i
don't know if you know my people but you
know i don't know who's the phoebe yeah
steve yeah and also a billion other
[ __ ] people
yeah yeah that's a lot of people i've
seen a lot of people sleeping in the
airport but before bieber before bieber
some fool in china or whatever said
this mushroom bull haircut
everybody got everybody gonna wear these
right
and it was some sort of government law
or some [ __ ] so not everyone's got a
bowl on their hand click click click
click right they all look like [ __ ]
ghetto [ __ ] beetles and whatever
right we're at
in china in asia wherever bro you never
it's only when the k-pop star started
going crazy with the [ __ ] rooster
hairs he tried to change it you know you
should testify this in the impeachment
here he just makes noise
but it would fit right in bro on c-span
what do you have you think about it
dude
yeah i think either go mullet or just
commit to um your roots yeah do you look
like yoko no no bro
you gotta do something dude
i
spoof dude
it's just you in the woods bruh
looking for something
but do i get to meet that white chick
yeah
i'll be on another honest thing i want
to say to you is that i've had um
desires of
using for some reason really which drug
weed
i have a strong desire to do it it seems
like you're going through just like a
feeling of like
like you're trying to you're not happy
like there's something i just feel lost
a little bit really yeah
do you feel like you have to always stay
sober your whole life is there a
pressure of that of that feeling i feel
like if i if i
i'm afraid that if i do go back i'll
have to do all the [ __ ] i did two years
ago which is like get shipped away
somewhere and inevitably you know it'll
be a crisis you know and i don't want
the crisis that's why i haven't done it
you know i mean but i was um in brooklyn
monday and i was at a restaurant
and the guy goes do you want a drink
and i this has never happened before in
my life i went i looked at the alcohol
drink menu
and i was like which one should i get
right and for some reason i want i'll
just have a diet coke
then he goes we don't have those oh what
is this guy right right and then he goes
um but we make our own
kind of soda-y drink
so i was like give me that then right
but i remember
almost making a decision to do it but i
didn't damn
i think partly because i had to shoot no
that was
i had already shot so yeah i think yeah
i would have done it i think
yeah do you think like can you like it
do you think like you just retire like
you're just
the world feels boring like do you feel
like you're angry like do you notice any
feelings about it no i just feel like
because of the pandemic and stuff that
like it's not truly over it people
pretend like it is but something's
different i feel like it's hitting me
now yeah like
during the last year i was fine i was
fine i was cruising i was cruising and
now
my head's completely [ __ ] in ways that
i didn't think could get there like i
hit him and i are going through
something similar where i'm like
i don't know what it is but i feel
something like shifting
and cracking inside me yeah but i think
it's a social it's a society thing i
agree with you i agree i do think i
think a lot of people are having to tell
a lot of people are going through a lot
i had six friends that's why my one of
my whole things about the pandemic has
been like all the separation is not good
like i've had six friends that overdosed
and died that i knew like six friends
right wow deceased gone
during this whole thing i mean we had
eric myers that comedian
god i mean that's a it all feels fake it
all feels like everybody and when the
things start back everything's gonna
turn the key and we'll be right back in
and i never got to talk about eric and i
want to talk about him now i never was
able when he died i never talked about
him
and uh um i just want to say that
eric myers was one of those guys i
remember being in dc
and this is years ago and and they go
this is your opener and this guy the
skinny white kid comes in
and just shy
yeah and i was like he didn't even seem
like a comic i think he looked like a
carnie yeah he did look at carnival
right he ran a couple of snowball stamps
not well yeah yeah
and i go go he once i saw him up i got
scared because i go oh [ __ ] this guy's
legit
like a killer yeah and every time i'd
see him perform he would kill but then
sometimes i would see him in the streets
and he was a homeless person yeah like
one time he had
i was at the store during the day
picking up a check and the manager goes
i think eric myers is outside and i went
outside he was wearing no shoes he was
wearing yellow pajama pants right and he
had any they were yellow but i but there
was blood
coming through the knees
so they were stained in there right he
had a gash on his head
but you know it felt like the blood had
coagulated on his head and dried so it
was like a blood knot like a kill bill
extra almost
yeah yeah and he had right down and he
was shaking he was like oh i need money
and i go and i and i know being a sober
guy
i shouldn't give him money but i think i
gave him like 300 to get a hotel room
and some food and stuff and then he
would get sober again he would look
great you'd see him perform and then
one day he just i get a call johnny
sanchez called me and said eric died
and i don't even know how he died i
think i heard he got run over by a truck
or something
big truck bus
did a bus really run him over yeah how
could have been a truck but how does a
bus run you over he got off no he got
off of a bus and got hit by a truck
is what happened
he got off a bus i think he got this all
speculation as well i heard that he got
into an argument on a bus or didn't want
to be on a bus anymore and i frequented
greyhound i get it you know what i'm
saying there's always somebody showing
you their dick somebody's selling you
drugs that you've never even heard of
you know
and you're you know you want it it's
just not it's bad yeah the bathroom's
out of order somebody's [ __ ] building
the air conditioning vent up in their
seat you know there's a lot of [ __ ]
diy [ __ ] going on yeah yeah but anyway
he got upset on the bus got off the bus
i was wandering around on the interstate
in the middle of the night and got hit
by a car
but it was because he'd relapsed that
was the thing that's when it's over for
a while yeah it's just a lot of people
struggle i think the separation
i think a lot of people feel that like
what is going on i thought i felt like
our society there was like a thing and
we're all part of something and now a
lot of it feels kind of
solimani or whatever
supplementary
like um
what does supplementary mean solumentary
it means like childish and by yourself
kind of oh that feels like it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make any sense
yeah i think that's what i'm feeling and
um
i'm scared baby
i'm scared are you really yeah
because i i mean i've been trying to
convince people
like i had dinner with a friend last
night and i was trying to convince him
i go it'd be okay if i was smoking weed
right
he's like no
i'm like oh okay but if you would have
said it i'd be fine with it i probably
would have done it right
but like i'm getting i i've been telling
my therapist last week i go
yeah it's strong desire of drinking and
she's like no so then it just kind of
kind of goes oh yeah she's right right
like it's been tough the pandemic's been
tough i mean people are [ __ ]
overdosing and dying so it's like
you know like it's been tough it's been
a tough time for me to stay sober i've
had some slips through the pandemic i
went off to that pcs one time remember
you told me oh yeah how long were you
there for i was there for a week eight
days or whatever yeah do you know
did you like it it was really awesome
okay yeah okay good i would go back i
think in january i'm gonna go do like a
30 day somewhere oh really yeah just to
get out of everything it's just
you know and we're making content all
the time things feel sometimes intense
and exhausting yeah um
[Music]
it's just a hard time and i you know i i
know you and i joke jokes and giggles
and we make things up but it's like it's
good to be gonna be easy on yourself
honestly yeah man you're my leader
sometimes man i know when i need help
man and i text you i say hey man i need
some help yeah i know i'm telling you
right now i'm on the fence man yeah i'm
struggling and um
i've been feeling it for a while i think
you know is it some of it angry you feel
like because i feel angry a lot of times
i feel anger yeah i feel anger i also
feel just kind of like
lost i just i can't i can't explain it
and i think that if there was in-house a
meetings and stuff like if i could go to
sundowners on sundays why don't you
they're not they're all zoomed oh
they're all they still are yeah and it's
like and it's weird it's like i can't
for some reason
doing it on zoom like because i start
playing like you know making my video
games on my phone right or like i'll i
remember me and some other comic we were
on that wednesday meeting and we're
telling jokes about people's eyebrows or
whatever
you mean and we would laugh at like look
at john's eyebrows right now and then
like you know you can do a side direct
message thing on the zoom right and we'd
be giggling it's not real you know
but um anyway
but you know what i haven't done it yet
and i feel good right now because i'm
with my buddy theo right
sons and daughters
brothers and sisters oh brother brother
sorry i'm not sending daughters i'm not
standing
sons and daughters this is not a
graduation
[Laughter]
sorry i scared everyone you know i mean
i i remember i i wanted to stay there
for a year bro actually when i got out
saturday i don't know when he came back
on saturday he cried the whole plane
ride home yeah he was like because you
know you you start to kind of connect
the dots about your life and you're very
clear because you're sober in this place
and you have all the support
and now you you're on a plane to go home
with all the things that have either
made you happy or sad and you have to
mitigate that on your own and you're not
so sure that a week's worth of
the help is going to kind of uh
um
has put you on the right path or not or
if it's enough or can you can you manage
so that that it's it's scary yeah it's
real scary that's how you went there for
a week yeah and friday there was this
dude in my group
there i'm not gonna say his name it
doesn't matter i know okay i'm gonna say
that can i guess one person no you have
to say yes or no all right go ahead i'm
just going to guess
um
[Music]
let me think
i'll tell you this
if you get it right i'll give you 10
billion dollars jesus
ten billion dollars
he's rich
you know what i owe it's probably
america's money he's probably on a loan
isn't it you know what i just got bro
what the core you did earth oh did you
you know the thing that goes
to make the gravity stuff right here bro
[ __ ] you elon
wow you got that score it's core bro
yeah good luck keeping that somewhere
yeah great crew's gonna get it you idiot
i know dude
and uh i
i remember leaving
levi that's him levi
you got you got the core bro
congratulations no i didn't you got to
keep us with me
i was in a group
from new york i hugged them we cried in
each other's arms for like five minutes
i never had that kind of connection with
another dude before damn right and so
when i left that place i was like
i don't want to leave but then
how am i gonna so i'm trying to bro
i'm just trying to get to the point
where you were like a hug in each
other's arms go back
i think i want to see that now are you
able to hug each other for a whole
minute deeply
no we're not
are we
without a bit without laughing and
making it a bit okay yeah i could do
that easily i think two minutes
one minute one minute let's put a timer
on here i'll put the timer on go in that
over there i'm gonna move but if you
laugh bro we start over the time starts
over who has a timer i have a timer now
this is gonna be hard
you can't laugh right smile or laugh you
gotta be serious well hold on make the
rules clear oh i'll make the rules right
now here's what it is it's already a bit
all right i don't like unclear rules
there's there's dialogue too
we can't talk during it no we we have a
little dialogue and i'm gonna give you
your script you can memorize it right
see now it's a bit no it's not a bill no
farewell my friend all right and i'll
say adios amigo whatever line you want
you want adios amigo
that's a bit it's not it's
it's a scene no it's not a scene it
should be just two people hugging each
other and forming a connection
heart to heart smile all right let's go
i don't
i need my beanie bro
is my hat on right now
yeah
hold on hold on joe burrow hello
shout out to the vietnamese in louisiana
too cajun crawfish
five 50 states for
vietnamese people i'll start the timer
when you guys hug
sorry i'm sorry i need a second
i'm good
okay they're about to die there we go
don't do
let's do it right here
and time begins now
fall into it bobby
be real hold the man all right
don't tap
think about all the things you love
about each other
asleep i think there we go
you smell a little bit older than i
thought almost there guys
we're out reaching about a minute
we're at the minute mark
they did half the time
you said one minute you said two minutes
no i went back to one minute oh you
changed it yeah yeah yeah nobody's
hugging for two minutes bro yeah people
have stuff to do man that's crazy
does it feel like hey bro but it's still
a minute people still got stuff to do
irishman
i won't even watch it it's horrible i'm
not watching somebody for three and a
half hours dude we should see it for
sebastian though have you watched the
show alone
it's the best show i've ever seen i
can't wait till thursdays when the new
episodes come out on history channel i
watched the whole series
on netflix so we just started first
episode on netflix yeah it's so good
it's really good it's so good does it
get better
it is so good man because we love it so
far yeah it's only you know what it is
can we tell the audience yeah i don't
know you know what it is no okay imagine
naked and afraid love it you love making
a friend here i'm gonna imagine whatever
you're saying and let me see if you get
it
imagine naked and afraid right except
you're wearing
arctic gear
clothes
right whatever whatever style
that you want right you get
just let me finish i am you're allowed
to have 10 items of your choice okay you
know
a thimble
you know what i mean
whatever you need
you know what i mean doxycycline
can you bring antibiotics on there you
ha that has to be one of them that would
be so smart just like a broad spectrum
um
yeah it's a great idea it's smart
thank you so you get 10 items right then
you get helicoptered in
to the north pole some people call it
entertainment yeah some people call it
where santa lives where santa live
that's three things
antarctica right north pole where
santana lives and some people call it
santa
or things antarctica as well the slang
yeah and then the ten contestants they
get dropped off in different areas
of antarctica
and basically the helicopter flies away
and then you go
the bay it's not antarctica it's the
arctic arctic five
that's five things right
and then um
they have to just survive
is there an end goal less less man
standing that's people tap out there's
no time limit yeah like one of the guys
tapped out after four days because he
broke his leg he broke his leg
but he was i was really rooting for him
too because i thought that he was the
best hunter of the ten yeah but he
didn't hunt [ __ ] baby he just said he
was the best no no he was like i'm the
best hunter and then he broke his leg no
his his profession by profession he was
a hunting guide and those guys are
patient because they'll wait like
they'll stay five days two weeks out
just for one deer they they have that
mental um resolve
we weren't able to see that ability
skill in action right you didn't see as
much of his skill yeah and it's so good
but in the first episode what we did see
is one dude
saw a squirrel
yeah
50 miles away on a branch 50 miles not
50. and what shot it and shot it right
through the [ __ ] temple one shot one
kill one shot one kill god so he brought
a gun no no he had a
gun dude he was bow and arrow he was a
bazooka okay that makes me yeah
rpg and he couldn't eat the [ __ ]
squirrel because he had a load this guy
alone it's blown to [ __ ] pieces bro
so right so important question
you guys are all one person what ten
items are you guys bringing okay this is
a good i'll get theo you go first the
doxie was such a good audience
honest ones yeah
do we get ten as a group ten as a group
tennis oh ten is a good one that's
better because it wouldn't but speak to
your skill though okay how about this
how about this we we're a group us three
theo me and kalila right
and we get to pick nine things
no three right because we get three a
piece okay as a group and then you get
to pick one thank you
you get to pick one so you're a part of
it too and before you guys say your
things present your skill set in general
okay here we go um
i have i have preserved
fat in my body
right so i don't really need
i could just not move
and get nutrients from all the [ __ ]
fat in my body okay i've stored a lot
number two so like a um parasite or
something what is that but you're a
parasite to yourself yeah i'm a parasite
to myself wait what are you bringing
this is his skill my skill set first
he's probably a skill set you're not
going to rely on me as much because i
need we're ringing tools right no but he
asked what our skills what what okay
okay yeah like he's a guy i got it i got
it right serenity is your skill set
almost really yeah number two right i
can i can mimic other animals okay right
yeah and they can sometimes you know
i've done it you haven't seen it
but not being real i don't know but we
haven't seen it you haven't seen it
because you don't see me in nature right
not true but i've done this
and i've had things land on my [ __ ]
arms [ __ ] impressive yeah i did see
yeah yeah not an animal but like an
acorn fall yeah you know what i mean or
somebody spit on his own yeah get off
this trail [ __ ]
it's a bit right on my arm i caught it
but i didn't caught it
yeah i caught it yeah i also have um
i can keep up i can uplift people with
my words yep that's true right positive
attributions yeah right and four um i
think i would go honestly this is the
true one i would go out of my way
i think and i'm like that in real life
especially not you but to her i would go
out of my way to make it see to make
take care of kalila amen
right so that'd be good so caring yeah
you'd be very i care for everybody like
a nerf somewhere yeah also i'm not also
i'm not come on there's a lot of things
you have but i'm not also greedy with
like i'm not one of those it's like
i hunted this [ __ ] muskrat
right so i get half and you guys share
the rest
i would equally you know
if you're filipinos you would eat that i
think people get weird when they they're
faced with survival yes and that is like
the mental you would have to have
trained yourself in really like dire
situations in the past to know these
things about yourself because i don't
think we know ourselves until we're
there oh i don't know it's a good point
yeah who would we turn into when the two
when they going what are your attributes
theo
i would say
if we had a had a game night or
something i would think that i would be
able to
like
think up fun games for us
i think i would probably be
the chef like regional chef
and i think that i would probably also
be willing to sacrifice my body
in what way in what ways
i don't know
uh-huh like maybe
um this is what i see you doing since
you're a very principled man i see you
getting the attention of like an
aggressive um male
moose during mating season oh yeah and
getting him real close so that i get a
good shot yeah
so that's a sacrifice i was willing to
risk myself you would you would risk
your body for my for heat
yeah i think would you i would lay right
in between y'all and just close my eyes
and let you guys be comfortable with
each other
you would be between them i mean or
around
i would lay penis down and let y'all
i would and i would have not even and i
would keep my ears closed and eyes
closed you all could do whatever y'all
wanted and just and i would just be real
quiet
hmm what's your attributes babe my
attributes is i'm very good with first
aid
okay
um huge
very good yeah i'm also pretty good with
identifying what's poisonous and not
poisonous and what's edible yeah cause i
would eat rocks
yeah i would eat raw yeah well you can
use gravel to help you digest food and
if we are by a close water source i am
very good with um
just water in general fishing and things
like that she's a water person oh yeah
your swimmer we could put you in there
hey we'll come back it's too cold though
if i had that's the one thing i would
bring with is a dry suit
a dry suit because i would attempt to
the first item dry suit
okay yeah but or that or you could just
like that's a selfie you could just fish
that's for her she's getting food for
you yeah you're right it has to be a
good thing it works so i would bring a
net one wow you're
we're gonna need you to step away from
the camp for a little bit
what i'm saying is that you just said
you have positive affirmations
what i'm saying is that she she gets a
[ __ ] wet she wants to dress up a
little bit we're going to be out there
for a long time we don't even know if
that's going to be enough for you so all
of a sudden you bring a wetsuit you go
out cold it's too cold no it dries a dry
suit you don't get wet bobby not a
wetsuit it's a dry suit you're
completely insulated and warm with a
hood and everything oh it's like one of
those old-school like scuba diving
things like early 1900s
gold things it's what the scientist
it's what the scientist divers wear when
they when they go after a leopard seal
yeah dry suit dry suit dry suit there's
no okay so i'm sorry my bad baby bring
that i i think that we would live really
well if i had a dry suit and if i if i
had a good if i had a nice spear gun i
could feed us every day
yeah but i would probably get lonesome
you guys have each other and then i feel
like i would get lonesome and i'll
probably have to leave and go do my own
camp at some point no that's negative do
you think that in this survival when
you're faced with survival that you
how many times in a month are you
jerking off
never
yeah i wouldn't jerk off on him at all
at all i would save everything unless i
unless it you know things got really
dire then i would jerk off for someone
else but i'm not jerking off for myself
a food source i wouldn't say i wouldn't
call it food i would say vitamins
that would get so desperate for calories
that i would you would eat each other's
[ __ ]
he said vitamins he said
bro he said good and planning
just come and i'm not eating any
regional semen man
would just come have protein like yes
some people say like nine calories
exactly right what is it i would rather
just suck my thumb and hope for the best
oh what about this what if i use my [ __ ]
as a glaze as a glaze as a demi-glaze
like i i make a salmon oh my gosh and i
put a little
gate glass that's the old place before
you guys started doing it in this
cut-throat garage
yeah all right
thumbs up comes down show them that
thumbs up whatever call it seem y'all
see real quick what if i was on my knees
25 calories per teaspoon of [ __ ] oh my
god theo i'm on my knees i haven't say
semen jesus what are you guys raised in
a damn we'll have to come in our mouth
again
i'm on my knees all right
i'm begging for 25 of your skeet
yeah yeah that's a lot of calories
you're not giving it to me but you're
not she's not going to blow you dude
we're going to take off a tree we're
going to jerk off beyond a tree and then
we're going to all run when we're about
to run and she's going over we're going
to go ah i don't know put it in a in a
cup
don't put it on a leaf back yeah
that's right i'm not putting in a cup
like some kind of center dude
[Laughter]
yo i put it on the back of a leaf and
then you guys can do with that as you
will
but i would close my eyes while you guys
did that or go be by myself so your item
is one is a dry suit a dry suit and a
spear gun spirit gun is number two and
then a fire star
i cannot i'm very very sensitive to the
cold okay and i don't do well with cold
so i have to have a fire starter a
reliable one yeah i would do sleeping
bag i would probably do
one of those lanterns
uh
and i would do a
um
decent axe probably a doll axe
is
definitely non-child actor
so that's like if somebody doesn't get a
kettle if you don't get a kettle i'll be
really disappointed cattle number one
then okay okay we got a boil i have no
option kettle number one hey that's
a condo a condo like condominium like a
downtown la artist like you know how
they have those portable houses yeah oh
like a double it's not a house
a [ __ ] double wide trailer yeah like
will smith has on a set yeah um
i'll call him yo dude i'm about to do a
loan connection he's not going to answer
dude and you can't bring that why it's
an item huh it's a full no it's a bunch
of items put together you have to get
one all right fine my bad dude all right
so um i'll bring the bed from the
trailer so a mattress a mattress
this is a team effort right he already
has a sleeping bag
yeah he won and i'll also hold my breath
while i'll sleep on my back
or i'll bring a tent
oh that's good that's good i'm good with
that 10 is good a 10 is good
10 is good
so i have the willow just let me finish
i'm not done kettle i had a kettle with
the kettle
not a kettle but how about like a pot
something that we can use to boil i
don't want a kettle i want a pot oh my
gosh
the same thing yes
okay but i want to call it
pot a tent and the third thing is um
this is a pole pot calling the kettle
right here
can i bring um
because we have to like gps can i bring
my ipad
no no no because you have to drive
you're gonna hit sam tripoli's tent
[Music]
you can't do that dude
all right that's not fair it's insane
i'll bring a compass
um i don't [ __ ] have to be as
yeah sounded good yeah cause you're not
really traveling places you're staying
in one spot yeah
about um i bring how about you you're a
fish net already who no i had a spear
gun and a dragon
i'll have a fish net
yeah because i saw it in the only one
bobby will be fishing at stockings on
accident he'll open up the package
oops
oops like he's like at least there's two
of them
so um that's it we would die
no i think we would do okay i think we
would make it
what do you guys think george how many
days would you give us honestly out
there
and the weather at first is like 25
degrees or maybe 40. right no snow yet
no snow yet but then by probably towards
you know every week i would say it drops
20 degrees or 10 degrees what's the
longest someone's done on the show
because we've only signed one episode i
don't want to tell them that because i
don't want to give away how long some of
it
that's is
that's that's not generous
i'll say i'll say uh i'll say 14 days
and i'm basing that up basically i'm
naked and afraid ish
wow
yeah it
because cold is
because you have the things you need to
survive like if you're just a little bit
here's the i don't know if you guys hunt
let's be [ __ ] honest i can i can get
fish
no you're never gonna no one's gonna
kill [ __ ] i'm gonna kill [ __ ] oh you're
not gonna kill nothing wait but i have
experience of killing someone you're
supposed to be uplifting
over there positive affirmation oh my
goodness i'm gonna kill everything
he's supposed to be uplifting our group
i know
all right not even out there
i get angry i get emotional no yeah yeah
but that's what i would that's how it
would be down day one uh we're killing
[ __ ] yeah right so you're right i can't
bring that energy yeah into the
situation right you have to leave that
out so i have to be like um four days in
we haven't caught anything yeah and i
have to make more pauses like it's gonna
happen one day guys yep
i'm i'm real confident in myself with a
fish guys
so if you tell me that you can subsist
on fish that i catch
and that you guys keep me warm because
i'm very bad with a cold okay we can we
can we can do it well i'll keep bobby
warm i'll sleep on bobby's like back and
he'll you'll sleep in front of bobby
well i mean it's like i feel like that's
the fair way to do it you know that's
the appropriate way to do it yeah you
know i'm not sleeping next to your woman
even if we're indoors or outdoors right
he's a principled man i'll be trying my
best then i'll be in
let's get naked we get completely naked
just hear me it's not gay why would we
be naked in the arctic yeah because
we're in this sleeping bag yeah right
imagine this
us three naked
in a sleeping bag i'm in the middle
kalila's in front of me
theo's in back of me and we're jammed
packed in a [ __ ] oh my god just hear
me out dude i'm just trying to hear you
out and it's hurting i know but just
hear me out we're jam-packed into a
[ __ ] sleeping bag right
imagine that now you're just like
sardines you're getting warm from our
bodies right okay and then the [ __ ]
um back the sleeping bag is insulating
the heat right
right and then all of a sudden i would
probably even ignore his erections
i wouldn't get it right i've got a lot
of records i don't think anyone gets
erected
yeah it's an erection time correction
this is survival time
i don't get erect when our freaking when
my life is on the line i can't get her
right in your broken glass even
yeah yeah so i don't get it right so
you're saying two and a half days you're
saying this ain't a hampton in do you
even know what we're getting into i feel
like you just
you don't really know what we're getting
into i know because i have i've only
seen one episode i think if i see the
series which i'm going to do tonight
yeah i'm going to burn through it all
right so in my head i'm going to be like
oh yeah two and a half days george had
it right yeah
yeah i i believe george thinks that well
you just you don't even want to go
camping
i mean are we at a movie theater i'm
gonna have one
what flavor kisses it these are almonds
not good i don't like the regular man
they put something bad in the chocolate
a couple years ago they changed the
recipe